taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
hey taste buddies welcome to the taste
buds podcast
my name's joe hey it's al guys we got a
hot one for you today we got a hot one
this is a biggie man
this is a big we've been doing some
titans in the industries lately and this
is no different
uh and i think they're uh
just like many other ones there is
possibly a favorite here
but uh let's not even get into that
let's not even name it oh you want to
wait to name it
all right no let's not name that's not
indicate what we think the favorite is
oh no no we don't have to indicate what
the favorite is but just to give you a
little backstory throughout history in
the history of snacks
there have been many snacks that have
utilized
cheese flavors ranch flavors
salsa flavors
see where this is going spicy flavors
yeah i like
the groundwork you land and a lot of
different snacks have brought those in
and incorporated these
these varied flavors into their own
product into their own way
and no two lines of snacks have done
this
more frequently and more prominently
than combos
and doritos correct all right you got
pizza combos you got pizza doritos you
got nacho cheese doritos you got nacho
cheese combos
uh i'm sure there's some kind of spicy
combo
out there you got spicy doritos you got
a list of combos mike you could pull up
look at that they got cheeseburger
combos i know i've seen like
a chicken buffalo blue blue cheese
buffalo and blue cheese
pumpkin and squash oh that can't be real
that's just best combination of flavors
in in the natural states
uh let's see what they got here yeah
here we go
combos uh you clicked on the link you
know we're doing doritos versus combos
yeah and i could tell i hope you're not
going anywhere stay
stay put folks yeah stay put you know
what mike just bring up that
there you go seven layer tortilla dip
combos
sweet and salty caramel cream pretzel
or creme excuse me pizza combos we
already said okay so that's a bunch of
those bring up doritos now we'll just
upload blue cheese that was in there you
got
you got salsa verde you got you got a
buffalo blue cheese dorito
right is that what you're saying sal
you got a uh yeah you got a not you know
a cool ranch obviously you know uh
what's the purple one spicy nachos sweet
chili sweet chili
sweet chili okay is uh one of the for me
one of doritos newest front runners i
think is
i think it can be put up against any
other doritos i think it's their best
doritos since the cool range they've
come out they've come out swinging with
that sweet chili
and also to to to liken these two
products even more so
doritos even did rolled up remember they
did the rolled up like taquito
style doritos that almost looked like
combos really
yeah yeah they got them at the top of
the page there they were see them in the
back there
where it says dynamite or whatever i
think you know we we could have done
something like
potato chip versus specific potato chip
you know like whatever
you know whatever your choice of you
know pick your poison if it was a
pringle versus a kettle coat whatever it
was or we could have even done
chip versus pretzel we started to talk
about it and we were like well what's
the ultimate snack i mean people reach
for a dorito
like if there's a chip in a dorito a lot
of times i think dorito is i think
dorito is universally known as
the most ultimate popular
you know everything you want to say
under the sun snacking chip
which is why it's amazing to me
yeah that you have for some reason
putting your name on the combo
today this is true because i don't think
that just because something is more
popular doesn't mean it's better
and i think if somebody's tune has
changed
i just think i just think that oh here's
another thing
we say this all the time we can't a lot
of times joe and i will discuss
what episodes to do what battles to do
what verses and
like for example cereal we both love
captain crunch berries
and we think it's probably the best
cereal so we don't want to throw away
the category of
cereals so we just put captain crunch
berries to the side
and maybe pick our number two or our
number three right right and we battle
them now you and i have agreed
off camera yeah about many many things
yeah we agree and then
we go how do we approach this number one
that has to do with this that we agreed
on is we have both agreed that salt and
vinegar potato chips
that's the grand slam of all grants are
the best potatoes i believe so
so we we were at a standstill with chips
but also chips
are such a it's potato chips it's so
broad
because i mean you're talking not just
brands
not just brands style style kettle cook
versus rigid versus regular traditional
versus flavors right and then you're
getting into
certain brands have certain flavors that
nobody else has and like
then there's chips that you can only get
in certain regions and then
if like like my favorite chips of all
time are hers
and i and then who's mine what
come on it's a little not just like a
class just some classic comedy for the
audience yeah okay
i mean you fell for it i did i did fall
for it who's her
uh she's a nice lady she's got chips
uh and then followed by utts chips
but these are chips you can you can't
just get these everywhere right is it
utts what i don't know
can you give us a pronunciation i always
called it utts i thought it was that's
but then i thought i heard them say like
let's hear him oh i think that's
nuts well that's how that person
pronounced
show me like joe utts and let me know
what he says that wasn't so much
okay so it sucks um but it gets
convoluted the chip and we wanted like
people that
we just wanted brand identity against we
wanted people that have just
have their steak in in also too
yeah i agree and these are unique snacks
like
there are other nacho cheese flavored
corn chips but
doritos are doritos period and there are
other pretzel filled whatever
but i don't know if there are actually
well there are other things where it's
pretzels filled with whatever peanut
butter but that's like a very generic
thing but i mean i would say combos and
doritos or
doritos have competitors direct i would
think parallel competitors
like the nacho cheese of that other
brand it's a it's like the gobots
of the nacho cheese what is it it's uh
it it
it was pretty popular especially when i
was growing up it was like it was a
little less than uh
like the bag that you got at the corner
store doritos was like 75 cents this was
like 50 or 25 what are they
yeah the nacho doritos competitor what
what are they called
there was a time when tostitos had uh
nacho cheese flavored chips do you
remember that
top nine competitors no this is she
brooklyn
it was the name of the chip it was the
name of the nacho chip it was like on
the bag it was
just type in nacho chip nacho
nacho chips chip brands or something
yeah chip brands
yeah oh well all right all right
nacho chip brands but do you remember oh
my god remember the old doritos bag
yeah yeah wow how fun was that
i know they do it again with the with
the taco flavor i don't like the taco
flavor well
my point is doritos have direct
competitors i don't necessarily think
combos do
there's no one doing exactly what the
combo but do you remember this
combo does you remember this back in the
day when we were kids
the direct competitor with doritos was
tostitos
tostitos had circular nacho
cheese flavored chips and then they
couldn't compete with doritos
so then tostitos went into the salsa
game with the plane chips and they
became
the go-to isn't that crazy
yeah i mean i don't i don't remember
tostitos being the
the the competitor that went away with
its tail between its legs it's it's
another brand as soon as you pull it up
i would recognize it they dropped the
nacho cheese chips though and then they
just do the corn chips they didn't do
that before
really they had a corn they started with
a coral with a nacho cheese chip i
didn't realize that tostitos
types and tostitos nacho cheese chips
so you can't even find these things
anymore it was a nacho chip that was a
number two
it's you know there at this point do you
know that doritos is king of that
i don't think anyone's doing what the
cops are up here these are up here with
doritos
that's what tostitos used to look like
where it had the cl they did the clear
bag and everything it's going to bother
me there it is
they're they're over here it's kind of a
classic look at that in the back look at
that classic look at that
new tostitos round tortilla chips nacho
cheese flavor and then in the front
tostito traditional flavor and they both
say new it was a new boy in the block
and and then what about nacho cheese
chips not doritos
i mean we having the same conversation
here i'm pointing some now i'm listening
i'm just multitasking all right
there's a podcast it's you know it's
based on discussion
i mean my mind computes different things
while you speak okay i know but you know
it's
it's i mean what are we what are we
looking for here
i mean i'm trying to get i'm saying i
would love to launch into this
i want to show you though the tostitos
look at this when they were new
yeah i know because you are i get it i
don't even know what that lends to the
conversation
you want to go on and on about the
tostitos when they were new why don't we
start now
so remember the smurfs let's start now
so you can lose this argument because i
don't know who you think is going to
combo is going to win i want to see this
to the listener doritos are amazing i
love them i love them just like you love
them
they might be my number two they really
do and honestly
i don't know if it happened when i was
younger but i think cool ranch doritos
i've had enough of them already all
right well
listen save it for the debate i thought
we're debating you guys
gonna do this all right but we're not
debating i mean let's do it
i'm gonna put it out right now better
snack combos
doritos tweet okay i'm gonna say this
right off the bat
right off the bat the only time i'm
eating combos
is if i have one dollar in my pocket
and i'm desperate to eat and i'm
starving and i need to fill my stomach
as much as possible with that dollar
it is a carb shock so you are so this is
the strength of the combo
you're down to your last dollar and you
need sustenance
because doritos fill me up because
single serving bag of doritos you could
probably get for a buck
so you're saying that you're going to
choose the combo bag for the buck
for your last dollar you just admitted
that you would choose the bag of combos
over because you can get doritos for a
dollar you just basically
you're opening statements i mean it's a
better opening statement just
completely destroyed your entire
argument you need something to eat does
it need it's mean it's a better snack a
lot of things fill you up and it doesn't
mean it's good
okay you know what i mean okay if you
said to me i got i got three dollars i'm
gonna go eat a bag of ice
doesn't mean i'm gonna go that means you
like the bag of ice best no it means
it's you okay but you but but
nonetheless you gave
you uh you gave combos a compliment
really did you
i don't think they're i don't think
they're worthless
you know i don't find them revolting
this is low
that's not a ringing endorsement you
don't find the revolting i don't i don't
i don't i don't think favorite is bad
i only eat them when i'm in it like when
i'm like when i like like
like the times i've driven myself to a
six like a gig that's six hours away and
i'm like
i just need something to put in my mouth
while i drive so i don't stop at another
drive-through why but let's let's it's
just carbs but but let's
let's uh you're saying the reason you
don't want to get a bag of pretzels
sometimes i will i want to get a
sandwich that's what
a bagel or a bagel because i just said
when i want something you reach for the
combo though not a bagel
[Music]
what do you reach for what does he reach
for when i want something smaller that i
can keep eating that will keep me filled
up i got a great it's i know couples are
great for that
yeah yeah yeah i know so it's a loaf of
wonder bread
doesn't mean it's a good snack here's
the thing okay
nacho cheese dorito i'll i eat them
sometimes till i get sick i get it
cool ranch i actually think they're over
hyped some people prefer the corn that's
one thing that dorito
i think that's why one of the reasons
dorito is so popular today
the ability to follow up the nacho
cheese dorito with the cool ranch dorito
and have it resonate with people nearly
as much i'd be interested to see pimp
which one has more sales because people
are loyal to the cool ranch dorito
i think that catapulted them into a
decades-long romance with people
as far as what they reach for the nacho
chip i mean cool ranch
it's yeah it's but that's just a
person's opinion so here's the thing i
mean it's it's
you talking about that's like the two
shot of the that's like the first two
weezer records
they went boom besides the sweet chili
which i think is
better than cool ranch and i think it's
their best second flavor
all the other flavors though are just
swings i mean no one's like i gotta get
my hands on some lime doritos
i gotta get my hands on this people love
salsa verde
oh god i i mean come on i don't but
people love it people go into the
musical
say crazy things even doritos loyalists
they go into the store there's there's
ten there's ten doritos up there no
one's going
oh my god thank you salsa you think
they're do you think those do you think
those other flavors are just sitting
there for no reason
i think they're moving i think they're
moving at a slow pace you think they
don't have their purpose i think it's
like when somebody opens a brick and
mortar store in soho neighborhood
because they want
the cachet of having a brick and mortar
store but they're really doing online
business
i think that's what's happening i think
that i mean cool ranch and nacho cheese
doritos are really the front runners and
then they're just like well we'll just
show them that we're all so
let me tell you what's happening when
you step to that doritos
rack you're looking at the wu-tang clan
okay and everybody's saying the same for
combos everybody's got their favorite
member
everybody's got their favorite remember
the nacho cheese
depends on who your favorite member is
for me it's inspector deck
that's my nacho cheese greatest verse of
all time okay
who's my sweet spicy chili method man
it's pretty good who's my cool ranch oh
stop i don't like this argument
no but no but i could do i could apply
the same accomplishment hold on let me
just say this let me just finish the
point
that said sal on my mother's grave
and she's not even dead yet i know i
have
never seen anybody eat anything
but the one type of compost oh you're
batshit crazy
because i would stand until you've seen
somebody strolling with a caramel creme
no the creme i didn't even hear of but
i'll put like the top five combos up
against the top five doritos flavors any
day
first of all you got your nacho cheese
pretzel that's the number one
uh i think it's flag yeah i think that's
their landmark like they're their
favorite
people eat that one and then the pizza
pizza i've never seen anybody eat any of
those
okay so the pizza one and the nacho
cheese pretzel one
i think and then don't even start me
because what the combo does
is it goes if you're not in the mood for
a pretzel i'll give you a cracker
they vary it you can get nacho cheese in
a pretzel form or nacho cheese with the
cracker form
cheddar cheese how about that even they
do nacho and cheddar but how about this
i was on now hold on the pizza cup with
the cracker combo oh then
how how could you sit here and have this
augment for me because i didn't know
they existed the cracker combo has been
around since day one it's a day day one
it's not a day one day one how dare you
it is not a day one
that could be proven right now that's
their cool ranch it came out after
pretzel combos were done
no no no i think combos released a bunch
of versions at one time oh no
yes look it up look it up but my point
being i promise
now i want to introduce you to pepperoni
not pizza
pepperoni cracker combo that's that's
like a trifecta it's like
father-son holy spirit you got nacho
cheese pretzel you got pizzeria pretzel
and you got uh
pizza you got pepperoni crackers you're
seeing pepperoni pizza cracker i'm not
seeing a pepperoni that's newer that's
that's a little bit newer oh what how
convenient i'm telling you right now
yeah combos i'll tell you nothing
there's no direct competitor combos
because
i don't know if they have a patent or
everyone just assumed they couldn't do
it any better
they're combining a pretzel or a cracker
and a dip
you dip you dip your nacho chips in
nacho cheese let me see
the combo is doing that for you
and it's it's in every bite it's
distributed in everybody let me say this
i've got so much more to say
let me say i know you do but we got to
take turns
let me say you went you just went you're
on the edge of the couch you didn't go
yet
because you got loud listen here's a
sentence that's never been uttered
ever in history i guarantee i'm the
first person to ever say this
i'm about to say hey before i come to
the barbecue
anything you want me to bring yeah could
you grab a bag of cheeseburger combos
there's another thing nobody said can
you bring a bag of combos
nobody has ever i disagree i disagree
you said
i'll
guess what if i'm coming to a bbq and
and i walk in and i got like a
bodega plastic bag i mean i throw it on
a thing and it's like diet coke or
whatever
and it's two bags of doritos it's
expected it's expected it's whatever
it's just expected it's not surprising
someone will be like oh cool doritos i
figured you'd bring something like that
i tell you right now i walk into the
same party and i think
yo and i throw down three of my choosing
three bags of combos people are
delighted in a way
that they're not delighted when they see
the doritos the doritos
are it's just like we get it we get it
but what's the snack that's taking a
little more effort
what's the snack that by the way by the
way combos
and and this is one you get back to the
edge again
this is something i want to say doritos
has got to put advertisements in your
face
doritos is like wait they're one of the
best to put hold on hold on yeah
has to put they do i want to talk about
this can we also figure out when they
came out to him
so look doritos let me tell you
something right now without a doubt
you're seeing a doritos uh
super bowl half time commercial without
a doubt they're going to spend two
million
super bowl money these
couldn't afford a commercial on a little
league broadcast baseball uh
you know what i'm saying that all
unraveled for you it did unravel but you
know what i mean
that's what i mean no no listen and hear
me hear me now when i say this
combo has sustained its product line
it's enthusiasm
it's it's it's fan base it's sales
off of zero advertisement zero
there's no combo ad in the newspaper
there's no combo super bowl commercial
there's no combo regular commercial
there's no combo combo jingle there's
nothing
doritos has freaking celebrities in
their commercials
so you think doritos are thinking
millions and millions of dollars to
buy to buy your loyalty when combos was
like yo
this is our product line you know where
to find us you're gonna you know what it
is
you're gonna argue humility
on behalf of this snack you tell me the
business you tell me the business
and the business model that will work if
you go i got an idea
and i'm just gonna make it i'm gonna put
it on a shelf the rest will take care of
itself
you can't because it's an anomaly
let's stop talking about combos like
george washington carver put them
together in his garage okay
they're made by the mars corporation all
right you think doritos is made by
but my point is is stop talking like
these combos are like the little
underdog that came along
with you know with the humble idea and
and doesn't get the recognition
you said to the underdog you said you
could reach for it when you need carbs
at a gas station
i'm saying let's not make it sound like
though that they were that that
you know that it's like tesla versus
edison and and combos are getting
bullied all over the place
and who made it true or false doritos
is the ultimate chip and it's more
popular and it's a front runner in this
debate true or false true
okay combo is better combos has
sustained 40 years
of loyalty of loyal customers with next
to
i can't think of a commercial and
advertising arena that i've seen for
combos
in the last 20 30. i can't even because
it's not worth advertising now that's
not why though and you know that's not
why
because they don't need to because
combos sell themselves
as a matter of fact combos if you're
gonna here's
here's a commercial it's from 1983 the
last commercial they ever needed
okay the last commercial they haven't
seen let me ask you a question let me
ask you questions let's watch it
let me ask you a question it is all
right i do i do remember that jingle i
was going to sing it but
there's a jingle that i remember from 37
years ago
the readers never edited also i'm sorry
this is a 37 year old commercial
with the jingle oh my god i'm sorry is
that a cracker right there the three
flavors
is it there
thanks for bringing it up it's it looks
like three better when you were too
young the original
i don't know it looks something done
something at that age there was no
original teat i was abandoned
again again this should not be affecting
the voting
1993 crackers combo look at that
1993 crackers combos that's not when it
came out
no that's just the commercial from 1993
buddy that's not that's not when the
kraka combo came out
look it up go to the combos wikipedia
that's what i love when you want to when
you want to base an argument on
something that could be debased
immediately
i can't wait till this gets to base they
weren't they did not come out of the
just go to combos wikipedia it'll tell
you they they
it it they did they did not drop
crackers at the same time
you but you know what's funny but in
fact you really don't know
you're just about to hope you that's
what i don't like that's what i don't
like you're
telling our listeners that they did not
drop at the same time but you know very
well you have
absolutely no idea if that's true the
idea
i have is because i didn't know the
crackers existed till today there's no
way i haven't known
for 40 years since the crackers so you
just say out loud that you didn't know
that
secrets existed until today but you're
going to tell them you know for a fact
that they don't want to come out on the
same day i want to tell you a story
you've never heard of it i won't tell
you story about combos
first crackers were released first
of all yes this
this you know what if you were a combo
flavor you'd be a cracker with on
the inside did you know this
they're also available in tortillas did
you hear that
they're also available in tortilla
shells
now now we're trying to even know that
now we're talking i don't even know that
now i'm listening so that's what they're
doing they're not advertising they're
spending their money on innovation
innovation not advertising the proof is
in the product
you bite into a combo that's all you
have to know okay
pepperoni pizza cheese
what mood am i in i'm going to tell you
something and by the way
there is no pepperoni flavor i like that
it was a bald-faced
eye there's joey pepper
you said it was just pepperoni pepperoni
pizza
pepperoni does not exist everyone pizza
cracker fine oh
no no no no no no no no no no no you
went out of your
way you went out of your way to go not
pepperoni pizza
why did i pay for perroni did he not do
i didn't want confusion between the one
that is deemed and has and has made a
name for itself as called pizzeria
i just didn't want those two one so he
said
i'm explaining what i said no no no no
no no no that's nowhere near what you
said
you said the exact words i'd like to
have brony pizza
yeah just pepperoni flavor all right so
what do
what what does that do for your argument
that i mislabeled one of them
you said some more too you said
that a tostito had a nacho it didn't you
said that then i pointed it out
you're pointing out a contradiction that
i accidentally said
instead of pepperoni pizza and not your
contradiction that you said crackers
do you realize what you just said you
just said crap do you realize
that these are stupid these don't you
they're eating you realize you're just
being meticulous
again i want to point out do you realize
what you just said you said
tortillas didn't have a nacho cheese and
it did when i said to you
sal i'm trying to point out to you that
the the tortilla the tostitos nacho
cheese flavor and you go
yeah i know what you're doing i can
multitask and you can't
because well well maybe we'll do an
episode on whether people think i can
multitask good or not just pointing out
my my my my
way for me i would like to go back to
something that we always visit that i
think is important
that you thumb your nose at and it
happened in chipwich versus ice cream
sandwich
and it happened in other areas go ahead
i'm gonna win this one too but go ahead
when i consider a treat and when i
consider what i'm voting for
i if applicable many times i consider
all the senses i consider everything
that goes into what eating a combo or
or dorito means and i think texture is
very important if you watch you know
these food shows and you hear the judges
and when people make these dishes
okay are the flavor combinations playing
off each other are they complementing
each other are you hitting
you know acid salt you know all these
different things the umami
all these things texture is always
brought up
the texture of a combo is something that
is not very common
in other snacks in this area because
it's usually just a chip
you need a drink with it you need
something biting into a combo and
getting a
snap and then and kind of like a creamy
center like a cheese and it it i do
agree very palatable and enjoyable to
eat it's very hard to find
a semi-hard pretzel that tastes as if it
almost went stale
filled with a cheese substance that
tastes like it's disintegrating as it
hits your tongue
i agree it's a tough thing to find it's
tough but they've nailed it god bless
you mars you nailed it
you nailed it right down okay what does
that have to do
with it being better than a dorito are
you gonna tell me a dorito doesn't hit
all these
you've got sweet you've got savory
you've got crunch
and what what i'm saying i i like
doritos but what i'm saying is if
honestly if i'm just oh my god
you may have remembered from the episode
of chipwich versus ice cream sandwich
how i was complaining
that the chocolate flavored drywall that
is sandwiching national sandwich gets on
your fingers and joe compared it
to cheetos dust and how much it's a
great thing
to which we all recoiled at home
doritos also have the same exact problem
if somebody's been dipping into the bowl
you know who it is
you're gonna ask questions just go
around you look at people's fingers i
don't want to walk away
with dorito dna on me if i'm going to
touch a dorito
either that's another thing i i can't
take in the whole experience
you're going to have yourself dorito
hands and guess what
dorito hands need to be washed with so
proper you're not gonna lick your
fingers like you you know what you love
gonna say this again you love to lick
your body after a treat
okay you love to lick parts of your body
yeah yes again he just said
he you just said you know who's been
into the bowl what affairs
are you throwing that you're serving
doritos at who is eating these with more
than one person
who is eating doritos with more than one
person a birthday party putting up
all the combos out at a baptism yeah
what kind of trash affairs are you
putting together i think that you're
going to get some hate mail on that
because i think most of the world is
baptizes people and most of the world
has snacks in a bowl
celebration i'm not talking about stacks
in baptism i'm talking about combos and
doritos
i've probably been to a baptism or a
family event with a bowl of doritos not
only that i've probably been to most
where it happens if you want to judge me
for that fine you know what i'm gonna
what i would say you're crazy if i had a
birthday party
uh an event a super bowl party a
christening
uh a backyard barbecue yeah there's
bowls of these things at all of them
and all i'm saying is you know what we
know what i don't want to be i don't
want to be in a nice slack with a nice
pleat
at a christening and start to get nacho
cheese herbs and spices
cheesy pretzel crumbs falling into your
beard yeah
that's what happens all of a sudden i
become oh because the combo doesn't fall
apart
when i eat combos i become captain lou
alberta are you going to act like the
the combo doesn't start to crumble apart
when you bite it are you going to act
like that right now are you in
what car are you going to are you are
you saying what i think you're saying
that you eat combos in multiple bites
yeah
my god if i was a cartoon
my eyes would have went like that and
steve would be shooting out like that
you you take multiple bites i take two
single crochet
and you need sustenance because you
instead of just
flying you're driving your new jeep that
by the way he's already went in the shop
you said that last episode i don't care
it still stands true
i feel like you have to but you buy
combos to ration like you might just go
hungry
that you sp who splits a combo into i
like to tweak two by chatting
i never heard
[Laughter]
it's not it's that big i gave a combo
i gave a combo to my two-year-old
to my two-year-old
you're approaching the middle of your
life
just just pop it in your mouth i like to
bite it in half first
that's an issue no one else has i don't
fear getting combo dust in my beard
they're made they actually have a little
bit of weight i love it
get a handful of nuts walk around you
know your home
and you're thinking and you just go on
cause you throw a nut in your mouth
you know how you snack on nuts no
because i'm not a contractor from the
50s
what are you talking about because i
told you i when i consider a stack i
consider the overall experience
i like it and snack a little weight in
it i like i like you know what i
i like reaching into a bag pulling out
three four combos
and i like walking around going like
this with me and i throw one in my mouth
and i got the other three
it's a very tactile experience i love
that they have a little bit of weight
into them there's
nothing more exciting sack wise that
when you reach that dorito bag and you
feel those jagged edges
and you know when you've got a good one
i'm sorry you better be careful because
the dorito might hurt your teeth
you're gonna tag your edges you you when
you the chip when you when the
chocolate chip morsels just wrecked your
gums combos
everyone is identical and uniform just
like hitler wanted no do you okay
every one of them every one of them
doritos diversity
to the fact that it was hitler's
favorite chip no no listen to me okay
nothing i do with a combo
i tell you i'd say i preach this all the
time if you guys are fans by this point
you know it's the overall experience
there's ways to eat something to enjoy
in a different way you know how you
could eat a dorito
you take a bite of it you chew it and
you swallow it there's only one way you
could eat it
you're mocking me you're not fighting a
combo and you're taking multiple bites
out of a dorito chip
no you throw it in your mouth no no no
no that's not what you said sometimes i
said yeah
i bite half of them and then they fall
overnight wow
whatever people shove into their mouths
like glutton
like gluttonous people you can never
just don't want to take no one reaches
into a bowl or a bag of torrito
pulls out a triangle and goes they just
go in they go
and it's crazy
oh yeah go ahead i'm sorry i choose
every combo i take out before
i throw it into my mouth i have a little
game to play i choose how am i consuming
this
sometimes i just let the pretzel roll
around in my mouth
i just let it roll around it's in a
cylinder shape it's pleasant i roll it
on my tongue i throw it over here and
maybe i bite a little bit a little
pretzel breaks off
i get a hint i pierce the pretzels the
pretzel framework and then i get a hint
of the nacho cheese
or a hint of the pizzeria and that seems
and it's a nice very savory taste but i
still got the
now the pretzel starts it's almost like
cereal when you eat it sometimes you
want full crunch sometimes you want
semi-crunch
you can choose how long to keep the
pretzel
the combo in your mouth before you
actually bite down sometimes i like just
sucking on it and getting all the nacho
cheese out of there like a treat and
then eating a pretzel after if you're
skilled enough
at eating combos you can pull that
you got different ways to eat it you got
a variety you got dip and pretzel
cracker in one bite
you got people that don't need to even
advertise you now got innovation
in the new tostitos uh you know the new
tostitos chip on the outside there's so
much going on
i mean if you think about doritos
doritos have been in the game and
number one for the longest time and the
best they've done is just in the last
couple of years
finally hit us with a sweet chili are
you the next are you
solid too are you nuts that's like
saying that's like saying man
coke's been coke's been in the game a
long time and the best they did was
oh they gave us cherry coke too are you
not you are talking about
the titans of the game there is no
second place doritos that's it
game over cerritos is probably more
popular
i asked people but also too
doritos and also too and and this will
be my closing statement before we go to
the head of the party you bring combos
you are the hit of the people
tell you what people do no one's
expecting a combo let me tell you my
point now
let me finish my point you cut my point
off let me finish my point and let me
tell you what people
say when you go to the party and you
bring comments they go that's
interesting
that's what they said no they don't okay
they go you know what i describe it i've
seen it in my whole life somebody's
people's eyes they go like this
oh combos you've seen it you have never
brought combos to a party because they
only come in a in a pocket-sized bag
first of all they okay don't they don't
at all try finding comments
don't at all joe these are the things
that you're going to want to just pump
the brakes on
when you throw out again
[Music]
hold your horses when you just throw out
these these you're just
lying now you're just lying it's about
the size of the pretzel nuggets
you make blanket statements that are
immediately debunked you did it three
times in this episode
you said crackers later as you said i
don't see what that has to do with
combos being a better snack
but don't try but don't try to take a
shot at combos with fake news
i'm saying you have never showed up at a
picnic with combos yes
i'll bet money on it and number and
number two
and number two this is how i would
describe i'm going to describe you from
now on when somebody goes
you know sal yeah i know so they go good
guy i'm going to go he's the kind of guy
to bring combos to a picnic
that's that's what i would go into the
city and watch their eyes as they go
by the way that's weird i mean you're
really hopping on this picnic thing
let's go to the post wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
hold on i'm sorry when was the last time
you went to a picnic
here a picnic i come to you know what i
mean a cookout
how many times have i been here where we
grilled never seen combos on that table
every time i swear to god not true i do
get confident you know what you know
what a lot of times combos aren't
available because they're sold out
they are i'm telling you the truth on
that one i'm telling you
oh right okay listen to me you're wrong
they come in bigger bags i've gotten
them you're wrong i brought them to
barbecues and parties
and you're wrong my whole life my whole
life when i wrote when i pulled up to
the bbq
when i pulled up to the picnic when i
pulled up and i dropped combos on the
table i'm
telling you i know the look there's a
combo's look i'll even coin the phrase
weird though that you just don't do it
at your own picnic oh that's right here
that you're so i'm sorry
i'm sorry can you zoom in on that can we
get an ounce on that bag mike
yeah no i believe what did it say at the
top dude what does it say at the top
dead show
the party bag a party bag try finding
one in the wild i dare you a party like
a barbecue or pickle
yeah try finding one of those in the
wild i dare you where you don't have to
order it on amazon
15 ounce 15 ounce bag doritos can you go
to doritos
show me find me one let me let me let me
do my closing argument
because you wanna you weren't ready you
wanna hit your whole your
your horse to this wagon that there
wasn't a larger bag that's a 15 ounce
party bag what is what is the uh
standard bag of doritos how many ounces
look at the three dollar bag like the
one that's like not a you're missing my
point
that's that's the smallest doritos party
bag
the uh you just you you party size 15
ounces oh
so it's available in the same exact
sized bed
look at that but you just heard it look
at that the guys that you just heard
them
the guys that spend all their no no
you're not hearing me you're not hearing
my point you said this
the windshield wipers can't keep up with
the rain he's getting famished
i picture just one hand on the wheel one
on the combo
he doesn't want to put the whole thing
in his mouth he bites one it's a pretzel
he wonders when did the crackers come
out
and then i just i just wait a second
hold on hold on i was just
taking out this bag of combos i just
said i just said
you're not listening to me i said show
me one
in the wild i could buy
i could buy a 64-ounce tub of peter pan
peanut butter
if i went on the internet and did it you
could buy anything in bulk on the
internet
you take me to a store so now your
argument is down to
you show me the brick and mortar
establishment yeah that has a bigger bag
of snacking take me to a store that has
big bags of coffee we can
we can we can do this poll right now get
in my car and go to
target or maybe we will or or whole
foods
it's a cvs website see if it's sold in
stores only in stores it says
fine so not available online the exact
opposite of your argument debunked again
not only are you getting debunked you're
getting proved egregiously wrong
in the exact polar opposite direction
you need to stop this
you need to stop this again if we go to
these polls right now and doritos wins
we knew it was going to be there they're
the goddamn batteries are better
doritos are the yankees god bless the
engines against them but my point is
your arguments are weak ass and i'm
gonna tell you another thing we can't
think on the heels of this
if i lose again at the losing a chipmunk
i think what we're going to do is this
i'm then going to take a poland this is
released not better
notwithstanding who won the poll who
presented
a better argument for their products
don't you because i'm getting sold down
the river
by this man because he has because i
think because i look because
they get riled up because i thought they
didn't have a picture because what does
it have to do with this
that's what you know what honestly you
you this this whole episode
you have done nothing you i i challenge
a fan take this video edit it
and put in a ding and every time joe
says fake news
okay just hit him with it okay and i
want i want to challenge a fan
to also put in an edit of sao saying he
can multitask what he didn't hear me say
that tostinos had nacho cheese all right
and the other thing i pointed out so
please
fan call out when i didn't hear him say
something but then the other fan
oh and how many times he says there was
peat pepperoni flavor
that weren't pizza right one time so it
was a big super cut but i want you to
know that
every single time you open your mouth
now he's googling and we're getting the
debunked information before you even
finish the lie sentence i admitted that
it's not a lie i said i've never seen
one and i said you ca
and i said i didn't believe you could
buy it in stores and as soon as i was
proven wrong i laughed
it's got nothing to do with the fact
that it's just
inferior snag let me give you a taste of
your own medicine
also doritos wait a second doritos
you know doritos are really our children
sold in japan also
all the doritos we have here are shipped
from japan we don't have to do with
whether it's a better snack or not
i'm not gonna pull a fact out of my ass
that i definitely don't know if it's
true or not
all right i made an assumption how much
stuff did you come here today
with up your ass because you've pulled
so much out already
i feel like you came in here like you
were going to vlog
you were crossing a border when
[Music]
on the walmart website the party-sized
bag of combos
was seven dollars the party size bag of
doritos
was 398. how big fans how many people
that spend all their money on super bowl
commercials
somehow are able to give a price at half
a snack at half the price you are
pulling so much out of you
how am i how many lies how many lies did
you have tied in a knot in a condom up
your ass when you came into the house
that you smuggled in here that you were
pulling out of your ass now i
said i didn't think it came in the car
i said i was wrong when you've proved
that i laughed
and then i said that the crackers didn't
come out the same time and i was wrong
and i laughed at both times i was wrong
doesn't mean it's a better snack i i
thought these episodes would
have more fun i mean you're trying i'm
upset this is like what you're this is
like when they're they're trying to get
on income tax evasion
i'm doing this for anything but the fun
i'm doing this with you for the fun i'm
doing this for the fun
and the connecting with the listeners
i'm not doing it for money
i'm certainly not i can't have you come
here every week
and just whip me up into this kind of
anxiety
i can't do it never should i want to
have fun doing this how are you this
upset
because i i'm happy to listen to to to
arguments based in fact and truth but if
you're gonna come in here and spew
baseless claims
and i had to spend an hour debunking you
sal you did first of all you have to
catch my breath in three minutes
you also said things that were
apparently untrue
we both did you said i mean think about
the pepperoni stack
and it doesn't exist i i made a
statement that i was like all right
i remember smoke i didn't hear what you
said no no you did it you said
you said i did it once you did it ten
times i didn't do it ten times i did it
twice
i said that the crackers thing didn't
come out the same time i was wrong i
admitted it
i said you can't get a party bag in the
store i was wrong i admitted it i don't
understand what you want to do
here i have never in my life go to the
polls see combos in the snack guys
let's go to the polls let's go to the
polls
time for humble
it's a pies it's never been this big
yeah it might have been this big before
all right it might have been i don't
know
with a 77 percent win
doritos superconductor i just say i knew
going in
that doritos would win it's a smart
money without a doubt but
so i mean i didn't think it would be 70
27 but but my points every point i made
i think is so valid and it really stands
and i think the 27
percent of people that voted combos i i
mean
go ahead they're smart or you're going
to say something like that wow these
people
these people are full of these
people all right let's go several people
let's this terrible let's read the
response i had compost right visit the
states i wasn't a fan
definitely doritos for re for me oh
that's another issue
that's another issue hold on combos
overseas don't exist
doritos are global
so that's a tough one it's a
tough one honestly well here's the here
sam morrill by the way says that right
up front disappointed by the turnout for
combos
yes as am i yeah he just shot a special
on a rooftop
i mean isn't that i mean i said you
shot zero specials that's just gonna be
a dick
that's funny uh uh all right all right
doritos
the rooftop was here in new york city he
didn't drive to idaho to bite and combo
i was like how did you know i said that
okay i'd choose
carrots before i chose combos and we
might have a winner
from tenderloin fan club sal's fans
turning them again
nah doritos sal is is this even a
combination
all the way all caps i have to go with
combos on this one it's
two snacks in one but they don't
taste the same now as they used to well
that's the problem with everything
oh and look somebody agrees with me
about comp combos are the greatest
road trip snack of all time
combos and it's not even even my counter
argument is getting
support combos and it's not even close i
have here
if it's a road trip gotta be combos
combos all the way what are combos
that's a big part of my disparity in the
percentages here
people are like i had i had combos when
i came to the states nothing beats a
sweet chili heat dorito
savannah again that was our winner from
last episode i don't even know what a
combo is
you can't combos all the way doritos
hurts my mouth
there you go your jagged edges right
there okay the same
probably how would a morsel a melting
morsel you have with a jagged stabbing
there's three sharp points on the dorito
and you have the nerve the
the unmitigated goal to just tell you
that
you like you're like when tyson would
keep punching after the bell
you got to stop the debate's over you
lost
miserably what the hell is combos
you gotta just i was gonna you got him
from the start you gotta
you gotta relax now you gotta let it go
i was doomed from a start
combos are the much better option a bad
shell and bad cheese
oh yes i don't know that they've tasted
more i don't know how they're
how they've lasted more than three
months this guy says yeah well they did
without any advertisement so go
scratch here's something that backs up
everything i was saying ready
this shouldn't even be a question it's
in favor for you but i'd like to
call this out doritos commercials are
the best the end
thank you okay thank you for saying that
because that doritos needs to be pushing
these commercials on you all the time
now did you see this thing
pepperoni combos by a mile to be honest
pepperoni combos don't exist it's a
shame
did you see this thing where this kid's
doing this this gif
with the doritos is that why you said
that because i've never seen anyone i've
never seen that i said it because it's a
universal truth and the reason that his
gif is resonating with people as a meme
is because it's the universe you can't
be the sore of a loser what the heck are
combos
this is i was doing from the beginning
guys i have no less than 15 messages in
a row what are combos
well well i i don't know it was your
idea this understands
i understand what i just want to say let
it be known the results are skewed
okay i mean there's no there's no doubt
about it the excuses you said this last
time because we called it the original
uh ice cream or the classic ice cream
sandwich that's why that one won
i can't believe you're getting this it's
just i voted combos but they're really
only a road trip thing pretzel combos
are filling when you're starving on a
road trip
all right all right i'm going to say our
winner is the carrots tweet and do
you did you find one better than that i
don't think so
i don't really care right now come on
sal
you can't be this upset what are combos
what's a combo all right i guess i'll
close out
uh combos are a great road trip snack
that you really hit on something right
there
yeah i choose carrots before i choose
combos that is the winning tweet it
comes from tenderloin
fan club at t loins fan club you can
follow them there
he she them maybe it's a group of people
i have no idea uh but whoever t
loins fan club is thank you for the
tweet shout out to angelo blando my boy
my sneaker
plug uh he says doritos if you're under
effing seven years old
combos if you're a real adult
shout out angela that's nice he he runs
a sneaker club
sal if you choose choose doritos i'm
reporting you
you eat combos in two bites and you're
you're you're coming down on a man with
a business
i'm just you know i have a business you
know just i'm not taking shots here
uh all right go to the joey rosa
sandwich pop-up if you're in new york
city at the stand
only at the stand in union square on
16th street we're open wednesday to
friday 12 to four in fact by the time
this drops the
the hours might have altered and gotten
longer
says that me and sam are out of all mine
so he's in the doritos camp hard
of course he is look at him yeah you
would think you would
for more sustenance he would like humble
um
come by the pop-up sometime and uh
that's that's about it folks thanks for
uh
thanks for listening joe rosa comedy on
instagram and twitter we should eat some
joey rose's sandwiches on on the podcast
one debate we should
nice bring a nice little sampling yeah
yeah that'd be great let's follow us i'm
sal a volcano on twitter but you kind of
hopefully you know that already i don't
know what else
and add taste buds pod on all social
media that's it that's a sports pod yeah
thanks gang
oh oh oh i just i still do you because
you almost didn't say it
i still love you i'm afraid you don't
love me i'm a little nervous for these
cameras to stop right now
the uh should i should i go like this
freeze it and we'll do it like a
seasoned cliffhanger
all right i love you too taste buds they
coming to the mic talking about the food
they hate talking about the food they
like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
taste buds if you don't want your purse
they'll take your pay stubs